BRET.
>> Bret: WE'LL KEEP ASKING
QUESTIONS.
PETER, THANK YOU.
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS BACK HERE
AT HOME ARE ONCE AGAIN
PREVENTING THE PRESIDENT'S
SOCIAL SPENDING MEASURES FROM
GETTING THROUGH.
THE DEMOCRAT RUN CONGRESS.
CONGRESSIONAL CORRESPONDENT CHAD
PERGRAM LIVE ON CAPITOL HILL
WITH THAT PART OF THE STORY.
CHAD, WE SAW WHAT HAPPENED LAST
NIGHT.
BUT HOW MUCH BLOOD, BAD BLOOD IS
THERE BETWEEN MODERATE AND
PROGRESSIVE DEMOCRATS?
>> WELL,BRET, PROGRESSIVES ARE
DEMANDING A ASSURANCES FROM
MODERATES KYRSTEN SINEMA AND JOE
MANCHIN IN THE SENATE THEY WILL
VOTE FOR THE SOCIAL SPENDING
BILL.
THERE IS ALSO DISTRUST BETWEEN
THE HOUSE AND SENATE.
THAT'S WHY LIBERALS ARE FORCING
LEADERS TO DO THE INFRASTRUCTURE
BILL AND THE SOCIAL SPENDING
BILL IN TANDEM.
BOTH PRESIDENT BIDEN AND HOUSE
SPEAKER NANCY PELOSI FAILED TO
CLOSE THE DEAL.
>> WHAT'S YOUR RESPONSE WHEN YOU
HEAR THAT SORT OF DISSENSION IN
YOUR CAUCUS ABOUT WHERE YOU
STAND WHEN YOU PRESENT A VERY
POSITIVE PICKS OF WHERE YOU ARE.
>> I HAVE RESPECT FOR ALL OF OUR
MEMBERS IN THE FULL SPECTRUM OF
THE BIG TENT THAT IS OUR
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
EVERYBODY HAS THE CHANCE TO SAY
WHAT THEY WISH.
>> MAD BECAUSE THEY BELIEVE
MODERATES PREVAILED REDUCING THE
OVERALL COST OF THE BILL.
PLUS, THEY NIXED FAMILY LEAVE
AND BEEFED UP MEDICARE.
LIBERALS ARE FLEXING THEIR
MUSCLES.
>> THEY ARE COMING INTO THEIR
POWER IN TERMS OF UNDERSTANDING
JUST HOW MUCH POWER THEY WE
WOULD ON THE HILL AND HOW MUCH
POWER THEY WE WOULD THROUGHOUT
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
>> BUT WHICH SIDE HAS THE UPPER
HAND?
MODERATES CONTROL THE POLICY.
THAT'S BECAUSE DEMOCRATS HOLD
NARROW MARGINS IN THE HOUSE AND
SENATE.
THAT DICTATES WHAT CAN PASS
LIBERALS CONTROL THE POLITICS.
THERE IS STRENGTH IN NUMBERS,
BRET.
>> Bret: WHAT'S THE TIMELINE
HERE.
>> THE BEST CASE SCENARIO IS
PROBABLY TWO WEEKS EVEN IF THEY
HAD A DEAL TODAY THEN YOU ARE
INTO THANKSGIVING.
THEY ARE A LONG WAYS OFF FROM
FINAL LANGUAGE.
THE OTHER MAJOR DEADLINE IS
DECEMBER 3RD.
THAT'S WHEN LAWMAKERS MUST FUND
THE GOVERNMENT TO AVOID A
SHUTDOWN AND THERE WILL BE
ANOTHER DONNYBROOK OVER THE DEBT
CEILING.
THEY COULD UNROLL ALL OF THIS
INTO A BIG BILL IN DECEMBER THE
OTHER DEADLINE WHICH OF COURSE
IS A BIG DEADLINE ON CAPITOL
HILL IS CHRISTMAS.
BRET?